Oh easy once you like get inside there
you're making my life difficult
this is just a bit
[Music]
yeah it's the ten right isn't that right
if I tell you I take no responsibility
okay every time this comes in was
disgusting part my entire life this is
like worse than watching any horror
movie ever this smells like your mama
mama mia pizzeria smelling the baby the
second step is to take everything
disgusting so now we come to step three
stab it like it's in prison I don't know
figure it out okay why are we doing this
[Music]
okay that moley then is that all you did
but who came up with this idea it's like
yeah you know what oh but it smells so
bad now okay it's my turn don't touch me
with that thing
hey Edgar how you doing yeah Gary are
you ready for this it's not bad yeah
well he has to learn don't make me teach
you how do you do your hands dude no way
and cut you up real good then cut you up
real nice baby
Oh
first
ah don't you don't you don't don't you
don't you okay yeah yeah yeah I like
this idea okay good job okay step for it
grab your pants you're not serious
step four you got started like you're in
prison but is this this is really cheap
[Music]
made a transsexual strippers if someone
gets hurt I take no responsibility so
you want to make sure you're never two
people doing this except for us
we can do whatever you want
[Music]
for maximum safety hold it let me do it
you let your girlfriend do it how am I
supposed to kill me with these I've seen
your power so if she rose why can we
comment telling us what you do for
Halloween just celebrate it I don't know
Oh pretty cool right you guys are gonna
judge which side is better yeah okay
you know in movies they always do like
thank you it's not really hurt okay no I
can't
[Music]
all right so this side is much that side
that side is my side right in the
Commons we SHINee prefer yeah I make
house business
[Music]
so thank you guys for watching hope you
have a and then put hey help me Edgar
[Music]